[Music]
so my name is sue be soccer and the head
of the particle theory group at the
University of Oxford in Rudolph pal
centre for theoretical physics but in
fact I don't just work in theory I also
work on couple of experiments once at
the South Pole it's called Ice Cube it
detects high-energy neutrinos from outer
space and another one is called the
Cherenkov telescopes are a which looks
for high-energy gamma rays but
essentially at the interface between
theory and experiment and my main
interest is in what we call
phenomenology in other words
understanding in terms of fundamental
laws what we see around us and so you've
done work on the supernovae that's right
so I'm not an astronomer but the
supernova data has been now made public
and our contribution was to analyze the
data in a statistically rigorous way
which we believe it has not not been
done in the past the point is that the
supernovae are objects which are just
like all astronomical objects they're
not all identical so in fundamental
physics we are used to the idea that you
know every electron in the world is
identical in fact you know John Wheeler
famously said it's the same electron
everywhere okay but supernovae are not
quite the same
however they are similar enough to each
other that they are used as what's
called standard candles they put out the
same amount of energy actually in
practice they're so-called standardized
herbal candles you can make corrections
based on how long they last and what
color they look to try to reduce them to
the same standard object and then you
can ask how faint are they looking and
then you measure the redshifts of the
galaxies they are
so that gives you a measure of the
distance and then from that you can try
to work out if the expansion rate of the
universe is you know slowing down or
speeding up or staying the same and
there was a major discovery in the late
1990s that apparently according to the
supernovae the expansion is speeding up
so in practice what did what they
actually measured is that the distance
of the Nova are about thirty percent
further away than you would have
expected them to be had the universe
been slowing down so that of course
raises immediately lots of questions
when you say that thirty percent further
away than you expected them to be
what if the supernovae had just become
in a 30% less bright right that's always
a worry and so the whole game is one of
trying to identify and pin down this
systematic uncertainties and that's
where I thought the subject was until II
actually looked at the data which was
made public in 2016 and then we
discovered that the statistical analysis
had actually allowed for the possibility
of uncertainties in each measurement and
they then tried to fetch the model of
the exhilarating universe to the data so
the point is that if you allow the
uncertainty on each measurement to be
arbitrarily large then you can fit any
mortal and indeed they did but if you
adopt a more correct word for it would
be a more not so much honest as a more
rigorous way of statistical analysis
called the maximum likelihood method
then it turns out that the evidence is
not really that strong and very recently
we have discovered that this apparent
acceleration is not the same in every
direction it seems to be highest in the
direction in which we are already we
know we are
moving through the Cosmic Microwave
Background so that's what makes us think
that this is not really the effect of
dark energy at all it's simply an
artifact of our being located in what is
technically called a bulk flow our
galaxy and neighboring galaxies are all
coherently moving in one direction at
several hundred kilometers a second this
is not the Hubble expansion this is the
deviation from the Hubble expansion we
don't know why it's doing that it could
be a big lump of matter nearby pulling
us here that as it may the fact that we
are in this bulk flow means that we are
not what we thought we were Copernican
observers we are not typical observers
we are very special observers and I
think that dark energy is an artifact of
our not taking account of this fact that
we are not typical why does that make a
special special in only in the sense
that we are not what the theory assumes
we are there's nothing fundamentally
special about it it's just like you know
I'm sitting at this particular spot on
this particular River back I could be
sitting at some other spot there's
nothing special about the spot per se
but depending on which sport I pick I'll
see the river River differently and does
this mean that if the evidence is for
that there's more experiments you can do
in that to collect evidence which isn't
a sport or why does it lead you to say
that it's not dark energy that it's
because the only direct evidence for
dark energy is the fact that it is
supposed to be causing this axillary
Tinh expansion so let me say that there
is a way in which we'll find out well
quite soon within 20-30 years because if
the universe expansion is actually
accelerating then what we should do is
measure the velocity of expansion today
and then ten years from now right that's
what you call exhilaration right and so
far all the measurements we have been
talking about are made at one point in
time
but quite soon with a new telescope
called the extremely large telescope ELT
it's being constructed right now in
Chile it will be possible to do what we
call real-time cosmology so you can
actually monitor the redshift of a
object and see it changing in time and
over a period of 10 years it will change
by about one part in ten to the nine but
it sufficiently sensitive the instrument
that it can measure that so this is
called the redshift rift and you know
people had talked thought of this quite
a long time ago but they thought it
would never be possible to measure it
and now with current technology we can
so whales know eventually if the
expansion rate is actually accelerating
but meanwhile apart from the supernovae
people have found other ways to look for
dark energy but they are all indirect
they don't directly measure the effects
of dark energy they effectively measure
the other components of the universe
apart from dark energy such as how much
matter it contains such as you know how
much space like sections are curved and
so on and then within the theoretical
model there is a connection between the
things that you measure and the dark
energy part the cosmological constant
which you don't and you infer that in
the context of the model but that
inference is only as good as the model
is correct say the model was which was
formulated a hundred years ago is not
the last word
for example the model assumes that the
universe is totally non homogeneous
smooth and every direction is the same
but in our real universe the universe is
very lumpy and we turns out that all
directions are not the same whether this
really has cosmological significance or
not is still under study this is not you
know what I'm talking about is not
broadly accepted by any means by the
majority of cosmologists but we do feel
we are on to something
because what we are doing is entirely
data-driven there's no theory in it at
all we are just asking a very simple
question is the universe isotropic is
the
homogeneous what effect would that have
on us we are at a particular position in
this network this so-called cosmic wave
of galaxies depending on the direction
you look at might be in for a different
thing than if I looked in the opposite
direction so these questions have never
been asked because the assumption has
been that all directions are equivalent
but you know our real life experience
tells us that you know usually that is
not the case and you can draw the wrong
inference if you believe in a degree of
symmetry which the real world does not
reflect so do you believe it should be
data-driven rather dance of grand
theories such as supersymmetry or blue
sky think oh absolutely because the
theory here was actually that has failed
miserably because that's what I talked
about in the debate earlier this in
Stan's cosmological constant he
recognized that the equation has a
certain underlying mathematical
structure that allows you to add a term
called the cosmological constant to the
equations he added it for the wrong
reason he thought you needed to make the
universe static and now we know that
actually need not be so and most of the
time the universe could be expanding or
contracting but that is not actually a
failure on his part at all he recognized
that the term had to be there and it is
not really Einsteins choice whether that
constant has to be there is there or not
so this famous story about how he said
it was his greatest mistake that has
never been documented by the way it was
George gamma was famous for telling fibs
making up stories who claimed that
Einstein had said that in a letter to
him but Einsteins none of his notebooks
actually show that you had ever said
this anyway the point is that that term
is there and that we understand today in
the modern understanding of physics
which is quantum field theory it
corresponds to the energy density of the
vacuum and the basic problem is the
the energy density of the vacuum if it
couples to gravity in the way that
Einstein thought of would essentially
have ever prevented our universe
becoming the way it is today so we don't
understand that this is the cosmological
constant problem
you know Steven Weinberg who is one of
the best-known particle theories there
is he said it is the bone in our throat
I think that really perfectly summarizes
just what a big problem it is we have
nobody has been able to solve it and
then after many years of trying to
ignore it because it affects nothing in
the laboratory you can do your
experiments at the LHC and elsewhere the
cosmological constant has no effect
there so you can't afford to ignore it
but not in cosmology that's the only
place where it raised its head again and
now astronomers claim they found a value
for it which is nonzero that raises
another problem why is it important only
today you know because the the value of
the constant is very very small it's of
order the other energy densities today
and the other energy densities would
have been bigger in the past so there is
a why now question so lots of people are
happily employed in trying to write
papers trying to address these questions
I think that no progress will be made on
that because it's a very very fine-tuned
problem but it has forced I think
fundamental theories to look at this
unsolved issue and I don't think I'm
clever enough to ever solve it but I'm
in good company nobody else in the world
has been able to do it either but I
think this is really you know the kind
of challenge that today's generation of
face is you know should look forward to
that there is something really really
major and important for them to tackle
that everyone else before them has
failed to solve and just playing games
with it calling it dark energy
quintessence whatever I think is just
completely are not only pointless so
that is just going to go away when we do
better experiments and discover that the
expansion is not really accelerating
I think we will discover that the
cosmological constant is in fact as
close to zero as we can measure it that
will bring back the old cosmological
constant problem which was bad enough
serious enough so you know this is a
win-win situation and if you're working
from a strong base of data why then do
your opponents find the biggest issues
in the work that you're doing they would
say that there are many lines of
evidence it's not just the supernovae in
fact most of my colleagues would say
that all we always thought there was
something dodgy about the survey what
about the Cosmic Microwave Background
that's precision cosmology what about
other things matter and acoustic
oscillations and so on the truth is that
all those arguments as I said depend on
assuming the answer they are inferences
in the framework of the standard
cosmological model if you broaden out
the standard cosmological model then
those inferences cannot be drawn right
and therefore I think there's these
people really ought to expand their
horizons a bit the reason why they have
not done that so far is because they
have been told that everything fits so
beautifully why you know why do you want
to try if things fit so beautifully that
actually is a selection effect there is
a strong evidence for what we call
selection bias so you know out of I
don't know
43 measurements of this cosmological
constant since the time it was
discovered you will find you would
expect to find a distribution right but
somebody who studied this pointed out
that they are all clustered around the
most precise measurement which was done
by in the past by something called the W
map satellite they're all within one
standard deviation of the W map
satellite that suggests that there has
been a unconscious you know bias in
determining the answer it is not
scattered so I'm very hopeful that the
next generation of experiments will be
done with so-called blind hypothesis
testing okay and that would certainly be
progress that's what we do for example
Daddy's ice cube experiment we open the
box with the data
only after you have formulated the
hypothesis that you are going to test
and what would the ramifications be if
you were able to prove that the universe
was expanding and accelerating rate well
that just means that we have to rethink
how to construct a cosmology and I don't
think I'm saying anything radical here I
mean our current model of cosmology goes
back a hundred years there is no other
domain of human activity I'm aware of
intellectual activity where we are
actually using a hundred year old model
to interpret data today we certainly
don't do that in particle physics our
standard model of particle physics goes
back to the 70s well okay so that's
already 45 50 years old but you know
it's not a 100 years old right and if
you think of other fields I don't know
neuroscience biology they're not using
hundred year old theories you know we
are in cosmology and the reason why I
think we have to move away from that is
simply so that we can be courageous
enough to accept the universe as it is
and not to try to impose this idealized
notions of symmetry and no perfection
upon it which is really what was done
and it was done because we had no data
then if you don't know something about
the universe anything about the
University you obviously assume it to be
as simple as is possible but today we
have the data so I think we really have
to start again and start constructing a
model of cosmology and hopefully there
will be the mathematical breakthroughs
that allow us to apply the general
theory of relativity to situations which
are not as symmetric as the original
model so this is not going to be easy
it's not going to be easy to take into
account what I said that you know you
might see different things in different
directions okay and that you're
particularly loquacious in the universe
might matter it just complicates things
and people say why complicate things why
not stick with the simple model
everyone's happy
well I'm not happy because it brings up
this dark energy
which makes absolutely no sense in
physics in fundamental physics
astronomers don't understand this for
them it's one number for us it is the
bone in our throat so I would like to
get rid of dark energy not because it
gets rid of the fundamental problem it
just brings back the cosmological
constant problem but it would allow us
to re-engage with that problem which I
think possibly will really require a
real advance in quantum gravity so
currently we have no theory of quantum
gravity which can engage with this
problem
neither string theory nor loop quantum
gravity have had anything to say about
the problem of how vacuum energy couples
through gravity so it will be forced to
confront it and that I think might lead
to progress are there any grand theories
such as like string theory or
supersymmetry ability that capture your
imagination well same theory certainly
captured all our imaginations when it
was formulated I was remember listening
in CERN theory lecture room - when the
first anomaly cancellation was
discovered in string theory this was
1984 and everyone was thinking you know
within two three years we'll everything
will be sorted out well that was what
was it over 34 35 35 36 years ago that's
because it has turned out to be much
more difficult than people thought and
no the idea was that the strings
themselves their dynamics create the
space-time amidst the strings move but
that has proved too ambitious a
construction so currently all of string
theory is formulated in a flat
space-time background in Minkowski
space-time which means that the real
dynamics of what string theory could
tell you we still don't know about it's
just too difficult it's already very
very difficult at this stage and the
full string theory nobody really even
knows what string theory is that's what
you know I know some real string
theorists and that's what they tell me
that it's hard to even formulate what is
string theory so in a sense I guess we
are lucky that we have hit upon
something like
which has got such depth and complexity
but at the same time
progress is frustratingly slow but then
that's really because we are impatient
if you look at the history of science
most things took kunal century to work
out and why do you expect that in 35
years we'll have dancers so I think we
should give string theory more time and
strength here is more time but they
should perhaps also be a bit modest and
not claim that they're going to solve
everything in three years and what are
some future research projects or
projects you're involved in at the
moment where is your where your work
taking it well as I said a
phenomenologist I'm interested in
phenomena rather than in high theory as
it were I'm saving that for when I
retire you know that's this is a joke
that you start thinking about the nature
of time and the measurement problem in
quantum mechanics you know and you have
the leisure and in the object because
they are difficult problems and you know
the code Goodell that's what he said
when he finally went to the Institute in
Princeton you know I really someone
interviewed him and he said what are you
thinking about and he said the nature of
time and you know so of course he never
made any other contribution to it it was
too hard so I think I'd reserve those
things for later but right now apart
from phenomenology of course I'm
interested as many people are in
information that's the sort of key to I
think understanding I know lots of
emergent phenomena like biology you know
what what makes a life-form different
from the inanimate molecules that you
put together to make life there is
clearly additional information in the
life form how that information got
embedded how it gets passed on that of
course is most of biology today how that
information is you know propagated and
propagated in such a elegant way and at
the same time extremely inefficient way
you know most of the information in the
DNA is not actually used for
synthesizing proteins we don't know what
it is for and there is clearly a huge
amount of evolutionary history written
you know in the construction of these
molecules and how they work together
that's all fascinating stuff but you
know we like to keep things simple in
physics we
like complicated stuff so the questions
we would ask are things like if I throw
a living being into a black hole and
then they get evaporated and the black
hole radiation contains the information
about this person that was thrown in can
we put it together and create that
person again so currently the answer
must be in principle can we do that I
mean that's that's actually become a
cutting edge question called the black
hole information paradox as to where
they'll forget about life even for an
animate object is that possible and it's
not so much that the answer to that
question itself is the be all and end of
everything but the act of thinking about
it the kind of tools that you have to
develop to think about it that creates
new you know ways of looking at things
so you know as with most intellectual
endeavors I think the journey has to be
the reward you know we don't really
expect to have a unified theory or solve
everything but we should have lots of
fun doing it finally where I wonder why
or if you think big ideas still matter
this of endeavor intellectual endeavor
why what drives you why what are you
looking for why should it be an
important part of our society well it's
like they say you know we climb Mount
Everest because it's there so the very
fact that we are impelled to think about
things that are not directly let's say
relevant to our survival that's I
suppose what makes us sentient beings
you know I'm not going to say things
like well it's thinking about these
things that make us wonder how to do
experiments to test them and then we
build a laboratory called CERN and then
we have a bunch of people in something
called the TC building who are there to
help the physicists talk to each other
and you know what one of them invents
something called the World Wide Web and
that changes everybody's life forever
right that's exactly what happened Tim
berners-lee was an undergraduate in
physics at Oxford at Queen's and he
worked in the TC
and he used to work with people who need
to communicate independent of you know
whatever and it that was not full scene
that was not planned and that's why I
didn't come out of Microsoft you didn't
come out of IBM it came out of a place
where people had just tried to solve
problems for the sake of solving
problems right so I think the material
benefits to human kind of what we do
should be bleeding obvious I don't need
to spell that out I don't know to give
you a list of all the things that has
led to but I don't think that that's the
main reason the main reason you should
be doing it is because we are creatures
who feel the need to do it just as we
feel the need to draw paintings on cave
walls and the need we feel the need to
dance we feel the need to make music so
intellectual thought is part of the same
you know glorious sort of set of
abilities that we have so you should use
them in the same way the only issue is
that it costs money that is true that is
why it has become a political issue but
actually I don't even need to say this
either it cost very little money
I mean who love CERN basically costs as
much as in one medium-sized university
so there are I don't know how many
hundreds of universities in Europe alone
so you're asking whether you should have
one or more one more or one less
University is that really such a big
question I mean so surely we can afford
this great thank you so much for taking
the time thank you
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you